nous
sommes des politiques ce matin
secrétaire nationale d'europe écologie
les verts vous souvenez bien évidemment
yannick jadot dans cette présidentielle
et on est ensemble pendant 20 minutes
pour une interview en partenariat avec
la presse quotidienne régionale
représenté par julien lécuyer de la voix
du nord où jean julien bonjour oriane
bonjour monsieur bayou bonjour et
l'actualité pour commencer du côté de la
corse julien bayou gerald arman ainsi
trouve actuellement hier il a longuement
discuté avec les élus disent c'est
d'ailleurs jusqu'à vendredi pour
poursuivre ces discussions gérald
darmanin qui est prêt à aller jusqu'à
l'autonomie par d'un calendrier qui
pourrait aller jusqu'à la fin de l'année
avec un texte à la fin de l'année en cas
de réélection d'emmanuel macro yannick
jadot lui s'est positionné clairement en
faveur d'une autonomie de long 2 lors de
sa visite en corse était effectivement
il y a plusieurs semaines à ce que du
coup vous êtes satisfait de la position
j'ai moi j'y vois de l'improvisation
totale et il a fallu un drame et la
tentative d'assassinât de yvan colonna
pour que le gouvernement se préoccupe de
la situation en corse ça fait plus d'un
an qu'il ya une majorité celle de gilles
simeoni président de l'exécutif corse
pour engager des discussions
l'assemblée des régions de france avait
déjà dit qu'il fallait envisager
l'autonomie de la corse
est l'une des monnaies les légendaires
emmanuel macron président en jacobins
depuis paris et discute quand ça
l'arrangé et donc là il a fallu attendre
une flambée de violence historique
dramatique
et peut-être un calendrier électoral
donc en fait on est dans l'impro la plus
totale et par respect pour la corse par
respect pour ces questions
fondamental de décentralisation de
l'autonomie ça se fait pas sur un coin
de table quand le ministre de
l'intérieur s'est réveillé plus ou moins
mal est-ce que vous pouvez nous
expliquer qu'on très concrètement
comment yannick jadot lui j'ai après là
c'est la situation on parle d'autonomie
mais qu'est ce qu'on met derrière ce
terme chez les verts nous nous appelons
ça la subsidiarité alors c'est un grand
mot de grand matin mais c'est en gros
prendre la décision au plus proche des
concernés il ya des sujets qui se
traitent au niveau européen l'évasion
fiscale le dérèglement climatique les
grands investissements et puis il ya des
décisions qui se prennent de manière
différente selon vous êtes à brest à
bastia ou à lille et en particulier
l'idée c'est de donner de confier à la
corse des pouvoirs législatifs ou quasi
législatif mais est ce que c'est le
régalien resterait deux internationales
et du côté de l'état mais on pourrait
avoir un pouvoir réglementaire ou quasi
législatif sur sur certains sujets il
pourrait lever leurs impôts par exemple
c'est oui bien sûr c'est une
revendication de longue date des
écologistes que les régions qui sont un
outil important et qui sont aujourd'hui
les régions françaises ce sont des nains
politiques ou économiques par rapport
aux länder allemands ou aux régions
espagnoles bien sûr que les régions
gagnent en autonomie y compris
financières mais est ce qu'on peut
imaginer un rapprochement avec le statut
de la polynésie française je sais
annoncé que l'état par exemple examinent
cette cette question c'est est autorisé
par un article soit 74 de la
constitution
est ce que vous pensez à ça moi je
souhaite que ce débat puisse s'engager
dans un dialogue hors situations de
violence voyez c'est toute la digue
s'est réveillé plus ou moins mal ça veut
dire qu'il a mal géré la situation
depuis une dizaine de jours ah bah
écoutez le problème au départ c'est la
situation du détenu yvan colonna qui est
maintenue sur le continent alors que le
droit permet le rapprochement c'est la
demande des familles c'est la demande de
deux un grand mais nombre de
responsables politiques aient compris
évidemment yannick jadot appliquer le
droit il fait la prison il est condamné
il ya eu des décisions de justice le
droit commun permet le rapprochement
pour éviter que sa famille et ses
proches
doivent aller sur le continent et donc
en fait il n'est pas accès à
ce droit tout simplement cesser cette
situation
de
non respect du droit qui a suscité
énormément de pension et à la fin on
improvise con que d'expliquer comment
pour des questions politiques
je pense que le gouvernement a voulu
faire le dur oui plutôt que d'appliquer
le droit et on est très très loin vous
voyez du respect du dialogue de la
concertation
c'est dans les situations
de concert de de
respect on peut envisager des sujets
aussi sérieux que l'évolution du statut
l'air et un dernier mot là dessus vous
demander le rapprochement immédiat des
deux autres membres du commando erignac
évidemment appliquons la loi a parlé du
plan de résidents tués oui plein de
résilience eux pour
contrer les sanctions les sanctions et
là les effets de la de la guerre en
ukraine il a été présenté hier par le
premier ministre est-ce qu'il est à la
hauteur des des conséquences de la
guerre selon vous mais là encore
improvisation improvisation c'est à dire
que
nous avons une partie de la population
qui est prise à la gorge par les
dépenses contraintes c'est le loyer
c'est le carburant c'est c'est bien sur
l'énergie c'est pas nouveau les gilet
jaune en 2018 disait déjà ça nous n'en
pouvons plus les salaires sont trop bas
et les dépenses augmentent notamment le
carburant qu'a fait le gouvernement pour
anticiper cette situation pour corriger
cette situation de vulnérabilité
rien rien ils ont improvisé pendant
trois ans on nous dit qu'ils ont géré
des crises en fait ils ont absolument
rien géré et donc à nouveau se pose la
question de l'augmentation des piques on
est rentré dans une phase où on va avoir
des crises de l'énergie des flambées de
prix de l'énergie et le gouvernement n'a
rien fait alors qu'est ce que vous
auriez propose excusez moi parce que en
effet il ya eu des réponses on va dire
paramétrique au travers du chèque du
chèque énergie ou bien la delà de la non
d'une baisse de 15 centimes sur sur les
tarifs et des énergies de l'essence est
ce que vous vous auriez proposez quoi
alors nous nous proposons avec yannick
jadot de longue date d'augmenter le
chèque énergie et de l'étendre à plus de
15 millions de ménages d'engager la
tarification sociale c'est à dire que
les premiers kilowattheures soit gratuit
parce qu'il ya une notion d' usage les
premiers kilowattheures qui vous amène à
18 ou 19 degrés stark la base du confort
sont plus intéressants plus utile que ce
qui vous amène à dessus à 21 22 degrés
donc les premiers c'est la tarification
sociale c'est la même chose pour l'eau
les premiers mètres cubes d'eau qui vous
permettent de vous laver ou de faire la
cuisine sont plus utiles que ce qui
permet de remplir trois étoiles et sur
son sol sur la taille sur la
tarification sur porto sur le chèque que
vous prévoyez sur le chèque essence les
chèques énergie ça ne ça ne résout pas
le problème de fond 6t systémique en
fait ça répond à des crises et à des
pics de prix tels qu'on peut laisser sa
route il c'est plus utile parce que là
aujourd'hui le fait de la réduction à la
pompe les 15 centimes est finalement
deux fois plus quand vous avez un gros
réservoir type suv qui pense même plus
en gros vous aider deux fois plus celui
qu'un suv avec des revenus conséquents
que la personne qui a une clio donc
c'est pas nouveau je le redis qu'il ya
des personnes dans ce pays qui doivent
faire des dizaines de kilomètres chaque
jour pour pouvoir se rendre à leur
travail c'est des infirmières qui font
plus les heures de garde c'est des
enseignants qui
consacre énormément de leur part de
leurs vous êtes sur la même méthode que
le gouvernement mais c'est plutôt une
différence de degré en fait
échec l'aide est indifférenciée disons
les choses laides étudiants et
indifférenciée quand c'est à la pompe et
donc on est beaucoup plus ceux qui
consomment le plus même s'ils ont des
revenus beaucoup plus conséquent donc le
chèque énergie et ciblées il est
augmentée il est élargi pour un plus
grand nombre de ménages jusqu'à 15
millions de ménages et puis engageons
enfin la rénovation thermique la
réduction des dépenses contraintes la
réduction de la vulnérabilité
il ya trois millions de passoires
énergétiques et 5 millions de passoires
énergétiques dans ce pays le
gouvernement avait promis d'en rénover
80000 la cour des comptes vient de me
dire que c'était en fait deux mille cinq
cent trente fois moins 30 fois moins
c'était déjà pas à la hauteur 80 milles
mais ils en font ils finalement 30 fois
moins qu'annoncé alors que c'est une
panacée cc c'est une bénédiction pour
l'emploi local pour l'artisanat pour le
btp c'est du gain le confort c'est du
gain pour le porte monnaie c'est bon
pour le climat c'est bon pour la santé
qu'est ce qu'on attend envoyé ça fait
des décennies qu'on le demande que la
fondation abbé pierre le demande la
convention citoyenne pour le climat
l'avait proposé emmanuel macron avait
dit c'est super la convention citoyenne
pour le climat vos propositions je les
jette à la broyeuse qu'est ce que ça
veut dire d'improviser autant et
soi-disant de gérer alors qu'en fait on
est dans l'impro la plus complète enfin
parler de le plaindre oui on passe à la
la situation dramatique on le voit on
continue de de n'entendre parler des
bombardements joe biden a qualifié
vladimir poutine de criminels de guerre
d'ailleurs les mots du président
américain sont bien plus fort qu'en
france où on ne souhaite pas le taxer de
dictateurs on l'a vu lors du dernier
dernière émission avec emmanuel macron
où marine le pen et son coût de pudeur
de la part d' emmanuel macron bah écoute
et oui il aurait dû dire mais admire
petit n'interdit que tu attends moi je
comprends qu'on entretienne un dialogue
parce qu'à un moment il faudra bien
organiser la paix simplement je trouve
qu'il ya eu beaucoup de naïveté ou
d'arrogance de la part d' emmanuel
macron de recevoir à versailles en
grande pompe
vladimir poutine d'ailleurs à la fin de
ce quinquennat finalement on reçoit le
sommet européen à versailles pour entre
guillemets corriger la naïveté
l'arrogance d'avoir reçu vladimir
poutine tout seul il ya une part de
naïveté vladimir poutine est ce que
c'est excusez le souhaitent est-ce que
c'est pas le fait justement de l'avoir
invitée à brégançon où à versailles qui
permet au chef de l'état à l'heure
actuelle d'avoir un contact assez
privilégiés avec vladimir poutine et de
pouvoir lui parler et de pouvoir lui
proposer justement des solutions
diplomatiques pour l'instant je les vois
pas je dis bien qu'il faut maintenir un
contact je dis pas que je crois qu'il
serait grand chose de ses démons de ses
longues conversations moi je le redis
invités vladimir poutine en grande pompe
à versailles c'est tout à fait différent
d'entretenir un contact diplomatique le
tutoyer
et l'accueillir à brégançon c'est tout à
fait différent de la cordialité
diplomatique on a eu c'est pas nouveau
et le traité de dictateur pardon de la
part par exemple de yannick jadot est ce
que c'est une façon pour vous
d'entretenir un canal diplomatique c'est
une
logique de dire les choses vladimir mais
vous pensez que ça favorise les
relations avec vladimir poutine je crois
que c'est important de dire des choses
bladimir poutine a rasé grozny l'a dit
martine à araser alep l'animal poutine a
envahi la géorgie au mépris du droit
international
vladimir poutine ce que c'est un
criminel de guerre l'enfant de neuf ans
je suivais ce que je veux dire c'est que
non mais si important de le dire si on
ne dit pas les choses et s'est classée
donc un criminel de guerre mais oui oui
et je pense que d'ailleurs la cour
internationale pénale s'en est saisi et
donc % des saisies mais pour l'instant
on le sait c'est vraiment impardonnable
est-ce que c'est pas envenimer la
situation a coûté celui qui envenime la
situation c'est celui qui envahit un
pays pacifique voisin on peut aller plus
loin dans l'escaladé entre les ans il ya
des complaisance coupable notamment de
la part de l'extrême droite on sait que
le front national qui est une campagne
présidentielle aujourd'hui possible
uniquement parce qu un oligarque russe a
prêté les huit ou neuf millions
nécessaires pour éviter que le front
national ne fasse faillite le front
national est un actif russe est donc
évidemment les soi disant patriotes qui
voulait protéger la grandeur de la
france était prêt en fait à sa
vassalisation ça n'est pas c'est
l'extrême droite qui est en fait si on
doit reprendre des termes malheureux le
parti d' anti-france on a vu la même
chose en autriche où c'était le premier
ministre d'extrême droite qui en fait
avait des liens les plus les plus de
maignon avec avec les y compris les
services secrets russes sur les 100 que
ceux qui s'opposent et qui permettent de
garantir une fermeté européenne une
solidité européenne face à
l'impérialisme russe ce sont les
écologistes nous ne nous sommes pas
découvert pro ukraine ou propre et en
ukraine armentières moi j'étais moi-même
au pied jusqu au juste
même chose quand jean-luc mélenchon jean
luc mélenchon je crois qu'il est plutôt
piégé dans une vision très
1956 et la conférence de bandung les
non-alignés moi je crois que quand il ya
un pays pacifique démocratique qui est
agressée il faut pouvoir dire où nous
sommes du coton fait une différence et
wii motion plus que jusqu'où il faut
aller et daté disons pour jean luc
mélenchon tout ce qui est anti états
unis et bien ils pensent que la
situation
dans ce monde en bout 21e siècle est un
tout petit peu plus complexe et qu'il ya
un enjeu de construire une défense
européenne nous le disons depuis des
décennies avec un pitch justement je
suis désolé les choses progressent le
débat est ce que les écologistes ne
rompent pas aussi avec une tradition pop
acier pacifistes et là sont en train de
vanter finalement les vertus de la
guerre mais le pacifisme ce n'est pas
regardé une population se faire
massacrer par un agresseur mais donc il
faut continuer à livrer des armes est ce
qu'il faut aller encore plus loin dans
les livraisons d'armes est ce que vous
êtes plutôt favorable par exemple livrer
des avions de chasse à la gouvernement
ukrainien c'est desmond tout prix nobel
de la paix pacifiste par excellence qui
disait vraiment si vous ne prenez pas
partie face à une injustice vous êtes du
côté de l'agresseur donc j'insiste là
dessus quand mais ça c'est de l'atc de
la théorie non c'est concrètement
concrètement ça s'appelle juste tenir
jusqu où va t-on dans les dents dans les
sanctions est ce que par exemple il faut
couper le robinet du gaz et du pétrole
alors que l'on n'aime pas forcément a
surtout mis les moyens bien sûr alors
non seulement il faut soutenir la
résistance ukrainienne parce que la
résistance ukrainienne se bat pour la
paix et la sécurité en europe toute
entière bien sûr l'ukraine a droit et la
paix à la sécurité mais ya pas de paix
et sécurité en europe si l'ukraine ne
peut pas en bénéficier il faut être très
clair ensuite il faut les sanctions les
plus dures d'abord ciblé à l'égard de
vladimir poutine et de toute son équipe
et de l'appareil d'état et puis il faut
et un sujet c'est que total doit quitter
la russie c'est pas possible que total
fasse des profits sur finalement le dos
toutes les entreprises doivent que
français va quitter leur qu'elles le
font pourquoi les entreprises françaises
donc au chant au chant danone toutes les
entreprises privées lallaoui finançons
l'effort de guerre de potable et très
localement
oui on va avancer julien maio un mot sur
les propositions de yannick jadot
matière d'école puisqu'il est présente
ce matin dans le journal la croix tous
les pays qui obtiennent de meilleurs
résultats scolaires que nous au moins de
congés c'est ce qu'il dit est ce que
clairement vous dit vous allez réduire
si vous êtes élu les vacances scolaires
ce que dit yannick jadot c'est qu'il
faut pouvoir ouvrir une discussion sur
les rythmes scolaires et présentera ses
discute cette proposition lundi l'idée
c'est une conférence où on prenne enfin
la vie de toutes les parties prenantes
pour se dire les choses très franchement
aujourd'hui les vacances scolaires elles
sont pas caler sur le rythme des enfants
elles sont calés sur les besoins de
l'industrie touristique du ski mais
cirque d'hiver et donc on a un truc un
peu bizarre absurdes ou en fait c'est
l'enneigement des stations de ski et le
fait que c'est moins de 10% des français
et françaises qui vont au ski tant mieux
pour eux mais vraiment c'est une toute
petite partie la population mais il
l'ensemble des rythmes scolaires de
l'ensemble des élèves du pays et rythmée
sur l'enneigement de certaines stations
vous proposez vous en fais donc une
grande conférence on puisse discuter
avec les parents d'élèves et prendre la
vie enfin des enseignants parce que
c'est vrai que réduire peut-être les
vacances scolaires permet d'avoir de
meilleurs résultats c'est ce qu'on
constate en allemagne par exemple où
dans d'autres pays de combien
discussions à vous vous ne travaillez
pas vous dire que moi je suis
spécialiste de l'éducation ce que je
constate est ce que je trouve
particulièrement absurde c'est que quand
j'étais élève eh bien on me disait que
c'était le taux d'enneigement à chamonix
ou ailleurs qui déterminait
la date des vacances scolaires je pense
que ça n'a pas de sens on m'a parlé de
président et manuel macron est en
conférence de presse cet après-midi pour
pour présenter son programme il était
temps
il était temps et côté on a une drôle de
campagne ou de pré campagne parce que la
campagne a pas encore particulièrement
forcément démarré avec a été évidemment
empêché par locaux vides l'ensemble la
population avait la tête à la santé à
celle de ses proches et qui est
désormais oui escamoté par un président
qui ne veut pas vraiment faire campagne
en plus exactement qui présente son
projet mais qui ne veut pas débattre il
refuse la confrontation en fait on avait
un président de la république qui
voulait se la jouer start up et
révolution démocratique et qui
aujourd'hui fait rentiers monarchique
ils profitent le plus possible de cette
position en surplomb pour ne pas faire
de confrontation il nous disait j'ai pas
le temps je m'occupe des relations
internationales et tout le monde
comprend simplement lundi il était sur
la chaîne tf1 pour un grand oral mais en
fait il ne veut pas débattre mais vous
n'étiez pas obligé d'accepter d'accepter
ces conditions nous nous sommes pour le
débat donc nous faisons
l'enfant
sauvage ils débattent d'ailleurs hier
face à marine le pen et ce soir face à
zemmour parce que face à la barbarie
face à l'extrême droite face aux menaces
à l'égard de la démocratie l'écologie
apporte des solutions et c'est important
de pouvoir le faire projet contre projet
mais quand le président esquive la
confrontation en fait ils esquivent les
critiques à l'égard de son bilan ou sur
la vacuité de son projet et quand gérard
larcher président du sénat par ledit
légitimité s'il n'y a pas deux campagnes
vous le suivez sur wii j'ai rejoint
gérard larcher il a pointé effectivement
un risque c'est que si il n'y a pas de
confrontation sur le bilan si emmanuel
macron et réélu en ayant c'est un peu
campagne sur les fonds publics comme
c'était le cas avant qu'il est donc il a
fait campagne l'arrêt et puis qu'il a
refusé la confrontation et qui nous
disent j'ai été élu à la faveur de la
situation
mon projet est validé on avait bien vu
déjà en 2017 et que des parlementaires
ne savait pas s'il avait été élu parce
qu'ils étaient candidats ou parce que
macron les avaient désignés ça pose un
problème de légitimité effectivement
d'arrogance et de légitimité du projet
et donc c'est pour ça que nous réclamons
à nouveau qui emmanuel macron daigne
descendre dans l'arène se confronter à
son opposition à un mot sur la primaire
populaire qui a demandé hier pardon à
ses électeurs pour avoir décidé de
soutenir jean luc mélenchon et non
yannick jadot qui était pourtant arrivé
deuxième à cette consultation à ce choix
qu'ils ont justifié le nom du réalisme
jean luc mélenchon étant je cite le plus
à même de gagner pour porter nos idées
au pouvoir qu'est ce que vous en pensez
ne nous laisserons personne nous dicter
le résultat d'élections je pense que
vraiment cette idée de suivre les
sondages évidemment être important tout
le monde tout le monde le regarde mais
rien n'est joué dans cette élection
c'est tout ce qui se joue dans les deux
trois semaines on nous disait que tout
était plié que l'écologie finalement
était un sujet un peu abstrait que la
question d'une défense européenne était
un peu abstraite la crise en ukraine
révèle profondément le fait que ce qui
se joue le 10 avril c'est pas juste une
élection de plus c'est pas un mandat de
plus ce sont des choix de société même
des choix de civilisation paix en europe
ou non plus nous vaut mieux d'europe ou
non je pense que les forces politiques
qui ont dit que la france serait plus
forte si elle faisait un pas en arrière
en europe sont profondément disqualifié
il ya l'improvisation complète du
gouvernement sur la corse sur la
question de l'indépendance énergétique
la vraie 1 sur la question de la
rénovation thermique sur la question de
la réduction des dépenses contraintes
sur le fait qu' aujourd'hui dans ce pays
on n'est pas payé la valeur travail le
travail ne paye pas ce gouvernement nous
a toujours dit que le smic était trop
élevé pour qu'on fasse un coup de pouce
et autres il ya un an des enjeux majeurs
de 2,2 climat de justice sociale de
démocratie on nous disait que tout était
joué et que cette élection était
finalement juste une élection de plus au
contraire voilà au contraire avec la
situation en ukraine mais qu'est-ce que
celle est ce que cette situation aux
fondeurs de vision des écologistes qui
avaient anticipé ces sujets depuis des
décennies et qui sont désormais les
mieux à même pour gérer la troisième
tenue continue d des derniers sondages
monsieur bail ou yannick jadot à six et
demi 6 et 10% donc avec quand même peu
de chances de franchir le pas du premier
but comme les tambours du monde que vous
voulez vous toujours autant que ce qui
est ou les commentaires du monde que
vous risquez miage à la campagne est ce
qu'il n'ya pas j'ai la possibilité d'un
accord encore une fois avec d'autres
forces de gauche pour justement vaincre
emmanuel macron au deuxième et les
commentaires que vous voulez moi je dis
aux personnes qui nous regardent enfin
comme en dehors c'est une question ne
vous laissez pas dicter votre vote
utile pour le climat pour vous pour vos
proches pour le pouvoir de vivre c'est
le vote écologiste tout simplement un
dernier mot sur les législatives où nous
confirmer que vous avez reçu une lettre
de la france insoumise
pour un accord pour les législatives
non mais c'est un truc de tacticien il
envoyait à libération avant de me
l'envoyer à moi
[Musique]
est ce que vous êtes prêt à un accord et
sensationnel avant chaque édition
savante pensez pas à la hauteur de leurs
espérances il envoie un courrier pour
dire qu'ils veulent faire une fédération
populaire ou qu à mon sens c'est
toujours un peu la même chose
la france insoumise et jean luc
mélenchon n'ont pas construit de logique
de rassemblement c'est d'un étang sinon
le parti communiste n'aurait pas fait sa
campagne par ailleurs nos coeurs a pas
d'accord pour les législatives avec
brawn et en tanzanie on se concentre sur
la présidentielle vu la situation le
redis je le redis vu la situation je le
redis les solutions écologistes qui
pouvait paraître un peu abstraite quand
nous disions fin du monde fin du mois
même climat comme temps nous disions
paix en ukraine climat même combat ça
pouvait paraître un peu abstraite et
logique de défense européenne les
logiques de l'europe est l'échelon de la
solution pour la transition écologique
on est en plein dans le mid ce sont des
sujets majeurs qui se joue le 10 avril
et donc laissons la campagne se dérouler
et chacun chacune prendre la mesure des
enjeux du vote du 10 avril merci merci à
travailler ce matin
[Musique]